bien maintenant j'accueille un jeune
auteur qui est le prix de flore 2010
collard et
nicolas raymond soir donc un prix de
flore 2000 alors le prix de flore faut
savoir c'est un prix très important qui
est d un prix vraiment à quoi brancher
un clairement on touche 40 mille balles
en plus un
et puis surtout alors c'est vachement
bien on a un verre de pouilly fumé 95
gratos pendant un an sur un verre en
cristal gravé à son nom par jour à large
revers par jour jusqu'au feu au café de
flore il fallait tous les jours boire
son verre de pouilly fumé 95 c'est bien
dans bien c'est bien pour ça on n'a pas
besoin d'avoir une bouteille ou 2 à 1
c'est moins bien alors votre premier
roman s'intitule et 13 minutes aux
éditions va là il avait déjà été
sélectionné pour le même prix en 98 vous
avez 26 ans vont enfin votre cv trafic
et donc j'ai même pas sur des jeunes en
réduisant 27-26 bientôt 27 lui mais les
journalistes journalistes culture comme
on dit au figaro magazine à technikart
le livre qui est primé s'appelle la
mémoire courte vous savez comment on
fait
vous honorez en le faisant jean glavany
giuly juge c'est pour ça que je le fais
d'ailleurs ne l'a pas fait il s'en mord
les doigts
ghoul à montebourg il est très mal bien
alors aux éditions au diable vauvert
alors il ya instruction va pas là c'est
pourquoi cette foudre si vous êtes un
joli garçon clairement mais pourquoi
quand vous faites un livre vue de cette
photo là debout comme sade anormalement
élevé par le portable aussi maison ils
ont évité
non c'est juste parce que c'est une
nouvelle édition un homme mario à zurich
s'est inspiré en fait de le des éditions
anglo saxonne avec ce format là la photo
c'est l'amérique il faut présenter un
petit peu le rejeter le pull bleu
voilà la tr min alors je vais raconter
l'histoire qui vous l'a comme entrée
c'est l'histoire de gabrielle qu'est
rédacteurs bande annonce à france 3 il
vient l'épousé de sophie est une
comédienne un peu emmerdeuse mais elle a
un grand avantage
elle accepte la sodomie alors il n'a pas
encore emménagé avec elle et le bouquin
c'est un petit peu un enterrement de vie
de garçon quoi c'est à dire i il est
marié mais avant de sauter le pas c'est
à dire l'appartement ensemble vous
connaissez sap où on en a parlé tout à
l'heure
donc voilà lors il enterre sa vie de
garçon alors il est un peu alcoolo
qu'est ce que c'est les morts à paris
c'est un cocktail cinquantaine que j'ai
fais comment mais en fait je crois que
c'est complètement imbuvable parce que
c'est un tiers au maintien whisky de tir
champagne ne doit pas pouvoir se voir ça
n'existe pas voilà donc moins quatre à
défendre la grosseur détails pratiques
anti communément beaucoup ici plus à la
peine alors il est un peu alcoolo un peu
défoncé mais pas seulement à l'aco qui
produit lexomil et du valium puis après
ils vous gardez sens il est au bord de
perdre son boulot il a du mal avec les
bandes annonces en fait une seule femme
voilà trois là deux copains qui sont
denis et frank gore en gros ce qu'on
peut dire sur ce bouquin en dehors du
style dont on va parler parce que c'est
pas que ça heureusement c'est qu'il
vérifie une dernière fois qu'il est
capable d'aimer avant d'emménager avec
as avec sa femme c'est ça ce qu'il a il
a fui il a menti pendant pas mal de
temps et puis là le même jour du mariage
et ils se réveillent difficilement le
matin du mariage mais jusqu'à
l'appartement commun où il a vraiment
les taux va se resserrer et là il va
être obligé de vivre à a2 quoi est une
façon donc très bonnes critiques je vous
conseille le livre je viens d'abord prix
de flore c'est pas n'importe quoi et
puis ensuite par lepoint journal le
point
et parle de vous et du cynisme exacerbée
autodérision hilarante désarroi émouvant
beaucoup de finesse et il serait hâtif
d'enfermer ce livre sous l'étiquette air
du temps l'express débâcle d'un enfant
du siècle sur doués de sa génération
on dit que les jeunes ne lisent plus
heureusement certains écrivent
on dit que j'ai les belles gambettes
c'est vrai
bon y'a que les inrocks qui vous aiment
un peu moins ils disent
pour nicolas réécrire se limite à
produire des bombes au kilomètre bah oui
c'est c'est toujours la même le même
domaine entre d'un côté la littérature
d'humour et après de l'autre côté celle
de l'idée un peu et de voilà les inrocks
qui oui je sais qui à mon avis ils
doivent juger que mon livre est trop
facile à lire en fête avec les inrocks
qui parle de littérature réactionnaire
de mode hauteur des yeux nasri des
actionnaires mais surtout il parle de
philosophie du grand amour rédempteur et
finalement il vous prend par un
alexandre jardin revu et corrigé par un
souhait lbeq
ça c'est pas sympa en revanche mais
c'est bien quand on fait des vivres il
faut s'attendre à tout beigbeder parle
vous comparent radiguet et dit cette
phrase qui vous définit très bien enfin
un livre bushiste dans un style droitier
vois ça je préfère ça il faut c'est
assez juste
alors madame c'est pas mal hein c'est
bien écrit
beaucoup de ceux 2011
soit douze savent bien étranges
commencent alors vous dites d'ailleurs
et vous vous dans la presse vous
déclarez il ya celles qui le font et
celles qui ne veulent pas en entendre
parler pour vous c'est discriminant une
vieille dame qui m'a raconté cette
histoire je ne sais pas elle venait
d'avoir lu mon livre je ne sais pas trop
rentrer dans les détails du bouquin de
peur qu'elles qu'elles ce choc et elle a
terminé donc elle m'a parlé très
brièvement du livre qu'elle avait aimé à
la fin il m'a dit et tu as raison pour
la sodomie à celle qu'ils font et celles
qui veulent pas en entendre parler voilà
mais étrangement ça vient plutôt de la
littérature ce il ya une vraie
littérature de la sodomie non mais c'est
vrai notamment 29 dans ses carnets noirs
il en parle très très bien et c'est vrai
avant tout un roman pendant que je bouge
bien oui mais c'est pas le même je vais
pas lire
je vais pas dire d'extraits d'accord on
va tout imaginer je préfère que vous
imagine alors je dis à nos amis
téléspectateurs et la page 11 de la page
132 et landi nisme c'est en page 46 47
en tous les cas j'ai beaucoup aimé le
libre et c'est ça
non mais t'as bien écrivent merci bien